we have a few more questions with our
friend Pearl we're having some fun we're
agreeing we're disagreeing but it's all
respectful it's all love uh then we'll
get some more questions with pearl then
she's going to flip it on me for the
last part of the show Nat I know you're
practicing your reading skills Hooked on
Phonics worked for Nat yes go ahead read
them out and let's see what this chat's
having to say awesome and then Malik you
can help me read the um the poll answers
if you want um okay cool well shout out
to you guys thanks for the super chats
uh we've got a few of them uh first one
is Bea and cheeks thank you for the
Super Chat is he in your chat yeah he in
your
chat he said uh pearls for sure annoying
and avoids real debates but respect her
annoyance because she speaks for the
weak men and in return she catches
women's attention I hope she gathers a
good female following to make her a real
change in society thanks p and cheeks
that was a good one Mr Cheeks um then we
have a few other um okay we have Uncle
Luke uh he said sorry Adam I got to give
you an l on your take about the truck
drivers I'm not a truck driver
specifically it's all about the
bluecollar men who keep the US going
that gets no respect Uncle luk uh then
we have uh a few smaller chats they're a
dollar when we go through them I don't
think so um okay well thank you guys for
the super chats we're going to be going
through like the $10 and up one so give
us some good chats give us some good
questions we've got Pearl in the house
so I think it's a great time to connect
Pearl let's do some rapid fire cuz I
want to I want to save some time for you
to ask me some questions I know that's
what we wanted to do so marriage M
marriage so you know you've had some hot
takes on marriage I don't need her to go
over everything you said but marriage
isn't marriage anymore uh we've talked
about the level of wives not honoring
their husband uh and you've obviously
warned all the men's of risk of marriage
but I want I want you to dream with me
for a second Pro dream close your eyes
dream with me you want to get married
one day I assume right so paint your
perfect life right your Ideal Husband
what does he look like what does he act
like what does he sound like uh dream
dream this dream with me um and and and
give us that ideal
lifestyle it's going to be such a corny
answer I want to marry someone like my
dad that's like usually what I'd say um
CU describe your dad my dad he's a
really hard worker and very like logical
cuz um I don't know my my life can get
obviously kind of crazy so I always I
always always like
um it's just such a ni I don't know it's
such a nice feeling when you have
someone you can go to for like guidance
um you know I'm tall so I'd like ideally
tall how what's all right how about this
what's the minimum height uh like 510
minimum yeah okay but yours 6ot 6ot you
like so you'd go shorter yeah well I
mean ideal like taller ideally but you
know okay how about this ready yeah I
played this this with the multiple girls
let's play the game with pearl oh wait
Catholic okay yeah Catholic so Catholic
priority um
Catholic put these in order it's sort of
um juvenile but I think it'll help
describe what you want you know whole
the 6666 game you played this before six
figures six pack 6 foot 6 in put those
in hierarchical order of importance 6
foot 6 in six figures six
pack
um I I guess
the I've always wanted I've always
wanted an athletic kid so probably the
the six foot and you just said 510 well
you I was going off what you said you
said the got it um then I guess the
money next maybe and six figures what
was the other one you said the six six
packs six Ines I get the six pack I
would say six pack and then what's last
the I mean those are the four options
right yeah so last is 6 in that's the
only one left so you're okay with a
short short man you know the song we
don't want no short short man gosh this
is so uncomfortable um I mean this is
this is your husband Pearl um I mean I
just I don't think that's the most
important thing wow most most girls say
ready six figures and 6ot first okay
then they say the 6 in thing and last is
the six-pack you know Nat talk said she
wants a wealth belly so here's what I
got here's your Ideal Husband does he
want to have a beard or no beard no
beard no beard clean shaven so we want a
clean shaven Catholic ideally six foot
man who makes good money uh with decent
shape not not not that important but you
know he doesn't have to be longdong
silver or anything like that he just
needs to be traditional devout Catholic
like man fair to say yeah sure yeah all
right do you have like a type like do
you have a type or you kind of like
black guys white
guys you're in Miami you're doing some
Sal
danc what are you into great great
question
um I like light eyes Okay so I like I
like light eyes nice Smiles say good
teeth yeah good teeth okay do you like
somebody like you know like what's your
I'll either I'll either date guys that
are like funny or they're like really
good like they're kind of like the quiet
like good listeners I would say those
are the two does make sense I know your
type okay fair enough
um yeah but I kind of like it's like a
plus if they come from like a similar
background to me like bigger Family
Catholic like that's kind of a you had
you have 10 kids in your family that's
no joke I don't expect it to be that big
but it's kind of like I don't know it's
kind of nice when someone has like the
same background as you you know it cuz
I'm Catholic so when I me I'm like I'm
Catholic too you know and so it's a nice
familiarity if you grow up in that
especially so okay so that's we're
talking about a men you know I always
say one of the things is that men needs
friends okay I've said I famously said
every man needs friends um every man
needs good friends but what's better to
that is having Rich good friends okay
but the best thing about that is having
Rich good friends who are actually good
people what we call Menches so I want to
know obviously you've
um taking a stance on women get it
what's your fre female friend situation
like are you still friends with all the
girls you grow up with are you making
new female friends is a lot harder for
you to get along with a lot of women
because of some of your hot takes on
women what's your friend status
specifically with women um well so I
have friends on my volleyball team like
I have a couple um I I've just NE to be
honest it's not really new for me not to
have like a ton of female friends I've
always just had like one or two and I'm
okay like I just don't need a ton of
female friends you know I I've just
always been the type that's been really
into my hobbies even when it wasn't
YouTube like I I was really into
volleyball I spent a lot of time doing
that um so yeah um so who who do you
confide in who are your close like who
you closest with other than family
obviously you're real close with your
your parents you got you're one of 10 um
outside of family who are you like oh
those are my people mhm well I have um
one friend I've been friends with since
like prek so i t yeah so I talked to her
a lot um and then there's girls on my
volleyball team you know I have friends
at work so got it so there's no shortage
of friends but the close close ones it's
very few yeah I mean that's just always
been how I've I've been like I've always
just had like a couple and that's just
been okay for me got it what do random
strangers come up and say to you like
for instance people come up be like hey
bro s love it love your interview Hy
that and some people be like bro I
[__] hate you but I got take a
picture man all good dude thanks what's
the most common occurrence when people
come up to you on the street I assume
you get recognized a bunch yeah right um
well after the Tate interview that was
like that's one thing I get a lot like
what was Tate like yeah um another one I
get is do you really believe what you
say and I'm like yes I do I think I mean
it even more in real life you're like I
love that question got it um do you
believe what you say um and I get a lot
of like I I get a lot of thank yous from
guys that have been going through the
family court system H so that that's one
thing they they they basically like
thank me for bringing attention to those
issues because it's just not something
that I would say is mainstream
interesting so uh do you would you say
you get more people come up to you that
Pearl I love you or Pearl I hate you
like if you had to give oh defin or give
a ratio definitely fans um you know I
can really only count I may only maybe
had five times someone's have come up to
me and like screamed at me in like two
years that's not so bad right year and a
half I don't know it's actually very
good cuz if you look at the comments out
there you think that everyone hates it
right yeah no not in real life um I'm
sure some people come up and like they
actually aren't like sometimes you get
the feeling where they're not actually
fans they're just like saying they are
you know they just say am yeah last
couple hot takes with our friend Pearl
then she's going to flip the script on
me um body positivity movement we've
seen a lot of that these days right um
you see the Victoria Secret they just
came out with the new documentary the
biggest beautiful thing
um you've you know called women whales
right you've made shirts about this I
didn't actually put those shirts out I
wanted to but no well you I've seen the
shirts I don't know if you sold them or
no I didn't gotcha so uh fat shaming we
get it you know but you know for men I
don't know if you know this the military
is actually 70% overweight right
overweight so this whole concept of
Exile uh acceptance and tolerance and
just let people live that's a slippery
slope right there I believe in
accountability I believe in truth so we
both agree that this obesity thing is a
big a big deal and needs to be dealt
with it is sort of again becoming more
common in society now I know you don't
think that women make great leaders but
we're going to play a game uh president
Pearl Davis president of the United
States of America go ahead wave to the
camera real quick Pearl go ahead give
him a wave hey guys vote for Pearl how
would you tackle this obesity epidemic
in
America yeah um oh the Obesity epidemic
I'd probably I don't really know I would
probably start maybe with the foods like
putting cuz don't they like poison the
birth control water isn't that a thing I
don't know I i' I've heard there's like
birth control in the water and that's
kind of messing everything up so I would
ban birth control that's number one okay
um number
two I was thinking what if men could
only get like the women could only get a
ring if they were like 150 lb or
less so in order to get the ring you got
to be less than 150 what about after you
got the ring you get pregnant never lose
the weight fraud that's fraud so what
would you do on that um is that grounds
for divorce oh yeah yeah that's okay so
that's another exception fr
yeah I think that's frud the same way
like a guy can't just stop working you
know got it what else anything else you
would add to the um I would ban about I
would ban lizo from all Billboards and
like media not I told you once that you
look like lizo you're beautiful like
lizo and what did you say to that I went
on my rant about it what did you say to
that don't insult me you're beautiful
like lizo thank you but don't insult you
look like lizo I I'm good thank you
Natalia just because we we already did
this got it no I understand but I do
think that there's something going on in
society yes where you can't comment on
something that is
obviously Obvious off yeah right so I
got an argument with a lady friend of
mine the other day where we were in
Miami and this lady had a fullon beard
okay it was clearly a trans situation
going on 5:00 shadow and then some and I
said yikes that's not a good look
something like that she goes you can't
say that I said why not sorry she goes
that's mean I
said yeah I know but that lady's got a
[__] beard what do you want me to do
she's like just keep it to yourself you
can't say anything nice don't say it at
all I go oh gosh
yeah but the lady's got a beard honey
okay and then we got this whole argument
of what you can and what you cannot say
and and we came to the determination
that I could say what I want to say but
I'm an [__] I go then maybe I'm an
[__] but that lady has a beard okay
and I I'm going to double down on that
so where does that go to that goes to
all the I can identify as anything I
want it's
like okay how H where does that slippery
slope go hey no matter how big you are
nobody can call you out on being
clinically obese hey can't say that
right so there's this there's this
something going on right now where it's
like if you don't like what someone has
to say cancel can't say that I think I
think the reality is is people can say
whatever they want to
say but the downside of that is maybe
they called an [__] mhm so I think
you should be able to call women whales
all you want thank you maybe just being
an [__] thank you I actually think
I'm being very kind and nice no really
really because they might not know what
if they don't know pear no I don't think
just like that lady knew she had a
beard have mirrors I I mean why if they
knew if they knew they wouldn't be
putting their blubber everywhere that's
what I say if they really knew they
wouldn't be in these bikinis they
wouldn't be showing their blubber on
social me they think they look good I
think they out of the kindness of my
heart I'm letting them know that they do
not but I think they know but I think
today it's being praised because I'll
tell you this any woman who's got extra
weight on her you you you know you got
weight on you like it's very clear to
feel it you you you do things
differently you're clothes for
differently like your confidence is
different so these women know it it's
just a matter of it's being praised
today I think I actually Oh I thought of
a law see I wish I wish I I knew that
question I I would have thought about it
all day I would ban plus-sized clothes
huh so we just have a bunch of fat
people run around naked that seems a
little counter be in the house they'd be
on the house on the tread they can keep
the clothes they have but yeah like I I
can't like get rid of them but from now
on we're not catering to you guys
anymore no plus-size seats on planes you
just can't fly get on the treadmill
start running um no plus-
siiz no no let's not do that I know you
famously said you just can't fly I know
you can't even over a certain weight I
know you famously have said that women
shouldn't vote what should fat woman be
able to
do
I mean what do they what cly I mean they
certainly don't do much now it's clear
by their body like how many how many
obese bigger women come up to you and be
like you [__] like how many how
many come right up to you and get all up
in your face I don't I've never even had
any to be honest I can't yeah the
internet okay couple last questions I
don't I don't think so couple last
questions looks look you know I I I I
make no mistake about it I love pretty
women okay the prettier the better but
also pretty on the outside and pretty on
the inside all good you know one of the
most shocking things you've said is that
you've tweeted this as one of your most
viral tweets you said an older woman the
older woman she is the less attractive
she is right you've also said a
16-year-old chick is hotter than a 26y
old chick right you also said you don't
you'll stand by that statement so do you
still stand by
that yeah in general to be honest I mean
they get fatter you know I just all I
did was look up the age of consent it's
16 so don't blame me blame the laws yeah
I found that out with Russell Brand that
I thought it was 18 but that's 34 states
in America it's 16 plus couple are 17
I'll tell you what inspired that tweet I
saw a picture of myself at 16 I was like
damn I was like a little hotti back in
the day so you think you were hotter at
16 than you are now yeah oh yeah no I
was now could actually I almost I didn't
want to keep playing into this cuz
that's just such a touchy topic like but
I I almost tweeted a side by side and
said where do I look better
W okay but yeah no um last couple things
that I don't I I want to get your
consent this we're going to go to kind
of like some some criticisms of you okay
and then we'll move to me so um we'll go
to him this isn't that bad I promise
okay but you know you have haters I have
haters we all have haters so this is
what I would call
Pearl response to her haters okay so um
our mutual friend Destiny oh okay okay
uh he said that quote unquote Pearl's
been falling off and she doesn't offer
much in terms of indivi individuality
that people would want to stick around
for okay this guy Jay Aubrey did he put
a hit piece out on you did you see this
no I didn't even see it he calls you the
unpickable pick me okay I even know what
does that even mean um on okay uh she he
says she doesn't say anything in
inspiring or insightful she only appeals
to hatred and anger on Pierce Morgan you
had a interesting banter with a woman
who said she's a moment in time right
yeah uh she's a train wreck and they
can't look away but pear will disappear
like many others before her so these
people these are their opinions okay why
do these people love to hate on
you I don't know you have to ask them
okay they probably got nothing better to
do so yeah Destiny it's it's interesting
cuz he he said that but I was just on
Pierce Morgan before I left so let me
know when you get on national TV my
friend gotta you know so you're
basically saying the proof is in the
pudding yeah all right okay nice try
buddy
um but you know I will say
that I mean everybody has ups and downs
in their career so do do I think you
know at some point I'm going to get
married and have a family so okay yeah
that you know so um the last thing here
you know the we all have critics believe
me I have critics especially on the pbd
podcast I've given some hot takes so
you're not immune from criticism I think
that's fair and believe me Pearl the
bigger you get the more criticism you'll
get a lot of women will basically say
that what you've done is sort of
contradictory right you're you're not
married but you Advocate marriage right
you're not a virgin but you say you
should be a virgin you say that women
necessarily shouldn't work and go to
college but you've gone to college and
you're CEO and you're running a very
profitable well-known company so what
would you say to the women out there who
are basically saying well she's kind of
a hypocrite she's doing the opposite
what's your message for the women out
there who are basically saying you're
saying one thing but doing another what
would you tell the women out there is
what I'm saying true or false is what
I'm saying true I say don't shoot the
messenger let me know if it's true you
know I I actually think everybody's a
hypocrite to some degree
um I think there's some choices I would
definitely change if I could go back but
yeah sure okay